this is a production of cornell
university
so thanks everybody for our live
audience i got a poll up there do you
measure growth on greens so
if you get a chance um fill that out
episode five
uh happy to have bill croiser of
university of nebraska-lincoln
uh came through cornell a couple years
ago so
happy to have him back on our cornell
turf show here um we'll get to bill
in just a second we're talking about
growth rate um but we'll start uh with
some cute images here from frank
i'm sure you always pull these off uh
somewhere on social media
yeah yeah yeah pay attention to them
thanks carl good morning everyone and
and big thanks to bill for joining us
and for those of you that are live
uh happy to have you here watching uh
happy to have you watching and
listening on the podcast of course happy
to have you there as well
and we continue to see lots of pictures
with
uh people in our in in the golf business
uh bringing
uh their kids to work uh and you know
they're just
uh they're just too cute to pass up as a
as a father and and speaking as a father
and uh
a pal of this guy john carlone and i big
shout out to john and leslie
uh sending their second boy into the
service
um uh just a
picture showed up on twitter just want
to shout out to my long time pal
and to leslie for raising uh two fine
men willing to go off to
uh serve us and and so we really
appreciate that and carl i'm gonna turn
it back to you
uh for your bmp minute because i think
it's pretty timely with maybe some of
the dry weather that's gonna be coming
yeah so last week you talked about a
little frank um there's there's some
areas of drought up here in the
northeast
uh you know cape cod area uh eastern new
england
um and i know we don't think about it in
march but you know starting up the
irrigation systems it's
uh quickly approaching and uh just a
really simple bmp tip
uh and we we have a as a par on here
right something everybody should do
uh just check your sprinkler heads early
in the year when you fire up the system
uh just visually checking them right and
that means going out
um you know the very simple version of
this is just go out and watch every head
turn
um so we have a good version we got
scott over here who's already
uh getting underway checking his
irrigation um if you got a drone
you know drones are great for pretty
pictures but they can be put to
functional
use throw them up in the air if you've
got a bunch of irrigation heads on the
fairways
uh just take some video and check make
sure those are all rotating
the right speed the right throw and then
the best case scenario
you can do the catch cap the standard
catch cup audit uh make sure
your coverage good but also the moisture
meters if you've got the gps function on
a moisture meter
that's a really good tool to do an
irrigation on it may be a little bit
easier than the ketchups
and also you get to see how the moisture
gets into the soil and that's the thing
we really matter
that really matters right it can land
one place and and kind of trickle to
another so uh that's our good better
best uh bmp tip of the day
yeah and i just want to say carl you
know back to the poster
and hard work here getting this done uh
drawing it to the simple things like
just you know
looking make sure and they're spinning
and working right checking your nozzles
uh simple stuff to get started right um
moving forward so listen let's talk a
little bit about the weather
um we're starting to see the season
progress now
starting to get uh above normal to the
southern part of the region
south jersey philly delmarva and even
up along the great lakes you see buffalo
rochester
batavia uh really a week or two ahead of
normal
uh way up there so so obviously the warm
winter
where the water doesn't get as cold
uh moderates that temperature and of
course may be leading to
uh some of the warmth that they're
seeing now uh it appears from what we
heard from our d guy tano this morning
in our
conference call and and what our weather
con seems to be looking at moving
forward
uh the predictions uh for the next eight
to fourteen days
uh are not only going to be warm but art
commented to us this morning that
he's never seen uh so profoundly dry
continental united states prediction uh
he's
got this uh sort of idea that
this is something that we don't see very
often and certainly something to pay
attention to and as carl indicated
uh particularly for certain parts of the
northeast
uh early signs of drought and he
commented directly on
uh ground water levels and and we heard
from some of our extension
uh agents throughout the state in the
region that stream levels are
a little bit low and it's not good when
we when we start off like this
uh with projected uh dryness coming
forward now
uh ian daniels uh did a wonderful job of
of
carl this is a good use of that drone
brother you know very easy to make
uh the claim hey you know this is why we
have to treat
this is what it looks like when we treat
uh it's
and snow mold is such a classic way
uh to see these differences and
particularly this year with kovid
um uh the you know whereas we're moving
out and
and people are are taking up golf in
droves and our and our play is
is so much increased uh having this good
early spring playing condition you know
right down the middle
right down the middle you know you're
not spraying out to the tree line you
know right down the middle right around
the bunkers
and and present this to the public and
i'm sure they'll be willing to
to pay for that now just a reminder this
is a picture from eric watkins his
research plots at minnesota that he's
participating in the
scan green turf grass variety trial
that's run through the
scandinavian turf grass and
environmental research fund
uh based in the nordic and scandinavian
countries
this is some fescue mixed into the
uh mixes here they're trying fescue
greens and fairways in this trial and
you can see
having some inherent resistance is also
a way to
continue to minimize it now it's not to
say the fescues are going to be an
answer
but uh understanding even in minnesota
where snow mold pressure can be pretty
high
uh the resistance of some of these
species can be pretty good
all right let's get into the i'm going
to try to do the best i can
to to set up uh my longtime friend here
bill kreiser who
uh on on a question that's lingering in
my mind and it begins with
with uh soil temperature uh where you
can see
just down in the philly area again in
the delmarva you're creeping into the
50s
uh the rest of us are pretty much
standard into the 40s of course
you get up into the north country in the
higher elevations you're still
maybe in the low 40s and high 30s
now we pay attention to soil temperature
as we talked about last week with rich
you know a lot for our early season
fungicide applications in the golf
business whether they're to greens teas
or fairways
we're paying attention to soil
temperatures in the 55 60 degree range
for fairy ring
and 65 degree range for summer patch and
so
there's a whole uh you know in the in
the um
in this particular publication the
chemical turfgrass disease control
publication that uh indicates all the
products and their efficacies
you see there's uh the proverbial
laundry list
of products that you can use that have
various levels of uh
efficacy uh against summer patch so i'm
gonna leave it at that and then we'll
move on to seed head suppression
and we're starting to see already uh the
early spring applications for proxy are
actually ideal
through much of the center part of the
northeast
um you're you're uh maybe marginal a
little bit to the south
and still a little early up north but a
lot of people
using proxy have moved to a fall
application so you've got a
a spring a fall application and a spring
application of seed head stuff
and bill's uh done a wonderful job uh
you know in many of his publications and
certainly with greenkeeper that we'll
talk about in
just giving you the general idea of when
you make some of these uh
applications of not just uh uh growth
regulators but you see the spring
broadleaf herbicide timer and we know
some of those products
have some growth regulating effects so
then we look at the early spring
uh applications of pre-emergent
herbicides maybe you're putting your
pres down on your fairways maybe
you're down in the new jersey long
island metropolitan new york
southeastern new england where
you know you're having to put uh pres on
greens uh
crab grass and grease grass control uh
on putting greens and as you can see
from the gdd tracker
you're looking pretty good for these
pre-emergence timers even though
uh crabgrass germination is quite a ways
off
the timer is indicating you can get this
product down
and then bill of course has uh listed in
in a gotham article about
how we apply growth regulators and the
relative
suppression we get from starting our
growth regulation and the interval
involved there
uh and i'll even set you up one more
time bill and say
you know you've you've put a theoretical
idea
out there about you know stacking of
this regulation over time this was some
of your early thinking
uh a number of years ago and so up so my
question
uh bill is is really simple um
i just went through uh the use of seed
heads
uh growth regulators for seed head
suppression
uh probably a fair amount of dmi
fungicides
for summer patch and root pathogen
control
i might be putting some pre-emergent
herbicides down
and i might even be starting my
traditional pgr program
how much should i worry about all this
pal
yeah hey guys um i think that's a good
question
um because it's something that uh i've
been dealing with um for the last
bit of time now i mean we're we're
building these growth suppression
models for different products and three
things that i've
directly studied are how proxy implex
growth rate
how dmi fungicides impact growth rate
and how
these growth regulators that are your
a's and your b's your primos trimets and
news
cutlass and all the different
combinations impact growth rate
and i think that's the thing that we are
moving
towards is getting off of this thinking
about products individually we need to
think about them as a whole as a
collective
sum and so my latest research is taking
a lot of the
modeling data that we have and then
grouping it together
to understand what levels of suppression
we're getting from all of those
different
products in combination and it can be
really substantial
uh where this time of year you know you
might see
10 15 suppression out of proxy you mix
that with a primo or a new you might
easily see 20-25
suppression added with a trim it some
people do for even more control
they can get 35-40 percent out of that
and then you start adding in a dna
fungicide you know i had some pink snow
mold popping up some like a document
patch has been cool and wet
and so it's easy to think well i got a
bunch of dmi throw that in the tank i'm
getting another
between you know zero to twenty percent
depending on the active ingredient you
you pick so you start adding those all
together you might be having 50
60 uh suppression so some of the new
models we do
starts to add all those together and
then
it gives a it makes an adjustment and
then it tells you
what we expect for the total suppression
okay so
but a lot of your work and this is why
i'm bringing this up this is why you're
here in the spring brother
is because a lot of this work and a lot
of that reference that you say to
percent suppression
is assuming you know active growth
you know look out the windows if you're
here in the northeast and listening on a
podcast or watching a video and driving
god forbid
the grass is not growing dramatically
we're at
20 30 percent growth potential bill does
this
thing this is what worries me is it you
know we
we put this together based on on you
know these products
and then there's the fact we're already
not growing at full potential
how much does that add to your concern
it has a ton and that's why
you know at our par 3 golf course last
week we applied proxy alone
you know it's common to do proxy with a
class a growth regulator
i don't like doing that until i start
getting my clipping volumes where i want
them to be
and so we started tracking clippings for
the first time we mowed on sunday
they mowed this morning just got out and
freezing still
and my clipping volume was high but we
had mode for four days when you
normalize over four days
you realize my clipping volume is still
lower than i would normally expect in
the summer
so i'm not going to put that premo or a
new in the tank
with that proxy until then if i'm going
to go spray for snow mold i'm not going
to go grab a dmi i might go grab a
different product that has less
regulated properly these are some of the
maybe the newer dmi's that that are also
seem to be a little easier on the growth
suppression side
because i want that grass to green up
and you know the grass that is green
right now
it's the polar you know not the bend
grass so if i'm telling people you know
i want to grow bench grass greens and i
don't want pola
the last thing i want to do is do things
to make the bent grass even slower to
green up
so let the grass start growing don't be
over mowing don't be wanting to
fertilize right now
don't be nuking them with growth
regulators that's going to keep that
bank grass from growing
the fertilizer is going to stimulate
more poa and the aggressive cultivation
is just going to also give the poa an
advantage
let's try to manage the bank grass and
let that bankrupt wake up before i start
beating it up with cultivation
growth regulators and nuking it with
fertilizer yeah it will help the
bankruptcy green up but it's really
going to give the advantage to the poll
well and there you go because we got a
lot of polar greens up here in the
northeast right
because of the traffic um that's really
good for
really appreciate you segregating it out
by species because it's certainly
uh going to matter and so let's talk a
little bit about that relative to poa
because i am worried about
uh summer patch on poa uh i do like to
have my seed head suppressed because it
just makes for a better
uh playing surface uh and um
you know i i normally use proxy and
primo so that's good to know
and i guess the answer to my question is
simply it's a good idea to start
collecting clippings
and monitoring growth right out of the
gate and i'm wondering
how long this is going to happen because
some people say okay frank i haven't
applied yet and that's why
i wanted to do this early because i know
probably nobody's applied
too much stuff yet i want them thinking
about it before they're doing it
how long are some of these regulations
lasting bill
in the springtime regardless of the
species
yeah so if you know at green's height on
poa
um if you're looking at an application
of something even like a new
and um you're looking at 25 days of
suppression
out of it and that's assuming an average
temperature of about 50.
so that's highs of 60 lows in the 40s
i'd say that's pretty standard type
spring weather
you're going to get 20 days out of primo
25 days out of a new
nearly a month out of your application
of trim it
and remember rate isn't important so if
you
think i'm going to use a lower rate so i
need to apply sooner nope
you're just going to get less
suppression but it's going to last the
same amount of time
uh we've been showing this now for 12
years it's not like it's a two year
little fluke thing here it's 12 years
of data that shows that rate doesn't
really change duration
it only changes the amount of
suppression so if you
are worried about these things and you
want some suppression
go out with the lower rates if you're
worried about that flash from an early
dmi or
the risk of a frost that can
occasionally bring that discoloration
use the lower rates um you know the
bottom end of the labels for the growth
regulators
to not get too much suppression but get
onto a pgr program so we're looking like
temperatures in in nebraska are finally
going to get up into the uh
the 70s next week their growth rates are
still starting to increase
and i'm probably going to do a primo
proxy app end of next week and i'll
probably do
actually a new in proxy this year and
just i'm going to do that combination
and that will start
adding my growth regulator but i'll use
a lower rate of anew
until my clipping yields get to where i
would need to use a full or higher rate
so
i'm always flexible with those rates
that try to hit my clipping yield goals
which for me are somewhere between
one and about 1.5 quarts per thousand
square feet
which is equivalent to 1.1.5 liters per
hundred square meters so
don't freak out about those units okay
all right
all right so listen let me ask you about
the seed head thing in particular see if
you got any data there
uh the fall proxy apps that you know
sean askew's pioneered over the last
several years
do we think that uh slows us down out of
the gate
um i don't know if i've seen it slow the
green up from the proxy i definitely see
the dmi fungicides with snow mold
definitely slow us up out of the gate
that's why i'm really
an opponent to people wanting to use
class b pgrs
at their snowmobile applications in
addition to their snow mold
active ingredients i know that was a
trend a couple years ago
and i've just seen a lot of damage
especially in this part of the country
with really slow green up and again a
lot of the bent and the blue grasses
are the ones that are slower the green
up the poa still kind of
seems to green up the same so that whole
thought process of
keeping the polo less competitive that
seems to be backfiring
so i haven't seen any issues with proxy
applications in the fall in terms of
negative
i've only seen a ton of positives and
that's really great seat head control uh
because we have looked at it
here i know we had a paper out that zach
reicher been working on
with researchers from i think like 10 or
12 different universities that have all
shown the benefits of those fall proxy
apps so i do proxy with snow mold
and then i do proxy by itself and then i
do proxy with
whatever class apgr i have on the shelf
uh for my second and third applications
how much does n rate get involved here
you know guys are trying to goose it to
get it going
um especially if your po is going uh you
know you're probably gonna
feed it a little bit with something how
much
uh can nitrogen i know you know your
classic
slide with the the three petals uh
again you know we don't have a high
growth potential but at the same time
you do see some response to end uh
applied early what are your thoughts on
on trying to kick-start it or maybe a
pigment to draw
temp uh colors to it what are your
thoughts yeah so this is the reason
i get on this on the spring end is um
we did a bunch of research in a growth
chamber um for
three years but we had like six
different cultivars
or species of grass and then we talk
about growth potential to me growth
potential is how well that plant can
make sugar
so when you're at peak that means the
plant is really efficient at making
sugar
but there's a disconnect between making
sugar and responding to fertilizer so we
did in our study was
put down different the same level of
fertilizer at different temperatures
and see what the clipping yield response
was so like your annual bluegrass and
your ryegrass
its peak fertilizer response is in the
low to mid 60's for an average air
temperature
the bent grass is mid to upper 70s so
that's where
yeah if you put fertilizer down now that
bank that poa is going to respond
way more favorably than the bent grasses
again that's why i don't like doing it
too much because it just gives the
advantage
to the other species i want to let the
bent grass be responding so after 60
degrees
now the polar response the fertilizer
starts going down
and the bent grass response is going up
so i'm trying to balance that ecology
view here of
let's try to manage the bank grass when
it wants to grow
and if i'm doing anything really early
because i'm really excited and i think
oh i need to get some growth
the poa is going to thrive on it because
it is ready to grow to try to make seed
and you know do its winter annual life
cycle well grass doesn't
yeah and and you know pola accommodates
a lot of spring golf up here in the
northeast and
because we don't have the or have
historically not had the intense heat
and dry conditions that turn it into an
a real
a real winter annual in your neck of the
woods uh because we don't have that
you know what i'm trying to balance here
is you know i see guys getting
themselves in trouble early with their
power greens maybe because they are
starving
them more and they're not paying
attention to the impact of the
regulation and furthermore
for those who want bank grass it is
important to say
put a lock on the damn fertilizer shed
because you're simply not going to get a
response that's that's what you're
saying isn't it bill
yeah and so i get some pressure from you
know people at the parks that the course
that we take care of oh we need some fur
on those screens like no
we don't want we've we've been
eliminating polo with with sand and
cultivation and all those things
but if you are maintaining pulse so we
used to have polar fairways
and so you know then we would make sure
that we're watching our growth rates
and that would definitely stay on those
proxy applications
because the plant is so much healthier
in the summer if it doesn't go to seed
we had one of the first years we did
that
that study we put her in the first
fairway because we had great poa there
well of course then the rest of the
fairway pukes out except for the center
of the fairway where we put down
the proxy and we had these like perfect
green squares for the whole summer
right in the middle of number one
fairway the most visible fairway on the
golf course
um because we were able to really make
that plant healthier
by aborting that that feudal seed head
production
uh growth phase so even in nebraska we
can grow some good poe here
it uh it struggles in the middle of the
summer obviously just like
you know within the northeast maybe a
little bit harder for us than
than it does for you guys because it's
just so darn hot um
but it still can linger enough to be a
nuisance and if you got poe fairways
you got to be on those proxy apps to to
keep that plan healthy if you're trying
to manage towards that or poor greens
that's right all right so listen i got
another question but carl are there any
questions from the audience uh
uh coming in that we could tackle here
because i got a couple of more things to
work through with bill or we take some
questions
yeah we got a good one from blake so uh
blake has been
um he actually has a test plot uh so he
throws down a
sheet of plywood there and when he's
applying proxy so
in the past he said that plot um that
didn't receive
proxy about a week after he applies he
gets anthracnose on the whole green
from what he thinks is drought stress
except for that little plot that didn't
receive proxy so his question bill is
um has he ever have you ever seen proxy
affect soil moisture
my question might be is that anthracnose
related to some
uh suppression of growth uh any any
comments on that
yeah i haven't actually measured that
but the way
you know what proxy is a stress hormone
ethiphone which normally
ethylene which is normally not that
important
for uh grasses it's not like it is for
like flowers that you know completely
just start dying under any low level of
ethylene
but it does still trigger this kind of
stress response and so
i don't i'm going to be speculating here
but i can totally understand how
maybe the presence of ethylene is
changing a lot of the physiology
beyond just and stopping seed heads and
if you're seeing that i'm not saying
that you're not
and the great it's great you have a
check plot so you could actually notice
it i mean that's how you really notice
that type make that observation so
um i think that is some rationale for
why that could happen
um so if you think it's a moisture side
just you know
being a little bit more aware that your
moisture levels might be changing based
on your own experiences at your facility
uh to try to minimize
any interactions that may be associated
with that moisture
issue uh and there's absolutely no
question blake
that based on the rutgers research and
i've heard this from buckley a hundred
times
uh any time even the minimal drought
stress
at the wrong time for annual bluegrass
is you know can be
can be enormously uh problematic in my
sense and i
think was this higher cut turf uh were
we talking fairways
carl or what was blake uh talking about
was it higher cut turf or
do you know uh i believe it's greens
okay blake if you've got uh he says
greens yep greens okay all right good
all right i was wondering about whether
it was in the short grass
all right listen bill let me ask you
because it's a speculation at this point
as we wrap up here
just a few minutes left we're we do
have a lot of golf courses that will use
dimension on their greens that might use
uh scots goose and crabgrass
control on their greens um what can you
speculate or what do you know or what
have you poked around about
looking at the contribution that
pre-emergent herbicides might have
knowing
that they're cell division inhibitors
and growth regulators in some ways in
their own right
yeah i don't have a ton of information
on that frank
i think it just depends are we seeing
that cell division happening
inhibition happening only at the root or
is it also having
any kind of impact on leaf the leaves
and so
most of growth occurs from cell
elongation the
elongating of cells have been increasing
in their size but if those cells aren't
dividing then they can't
elongate right so it's going to shut
down both processes so
[Music]
i think you you might have a
contribution there i have seen
some issues with dimension being applied
um here in nebraska and then we've had
some real issues with uh
newer bank graphs uh stolen's not
pegging very well with the at the roots
into the soil
and kind of pulls up but
that was just a couple occasions it
wasn't replicated research
i know though for even me at our par 3
golf course we got a lot of goose and
crabgrass and our putting greens this is
gruesome crabgrass central in this part
of the world
and uh and looking for options there is
something that i'm constantly trying to
figure out myself too i think sean askew
you might have had some some research
with that
i saw on twitter a couple years ago they
might have to dig up i don't know if you
remember any of that frank and what he
was using
to help with goose grass control in
greens but uh
i'm not really sure on the growth
regulator side because it's just a niche
that really hasn't been
studied that well uh in my lab yeah he's
been looking at
uh i think he's been looking at pylex um
for
goose grass control uh in the early
phase um
and i think uh let me just color it in
and you're right bill
most of what we know about pre-emergent
herbicides that we know forever is that
they seem to be primarily impacting
rooting
yeah you get you get clubbing right you
get that that pronounced clubbing
they just become these clubs instead of
you know
fibers um and of course over time
uh actually plants can live like that
with that root clubbing
for a little while because the roots
function but if you get obviously young
plants or
plants trying to peg in like the bent
grass you described
that can be problematic now listen bill
i don't want to open up this can of
worms but i'm probably gonna i'll tell
you right now we're gonna have you back
either for here or in the sports turf
world because i want to talk about
some of the stuff we talked last year
during the early days of the pandemic
and you guys have been doing
with the impact of these growth
regulators on ryegrass fairways on
kentucky bluegrass
sports fields and some of these other
grasses that
people have on tees uh and fairways
that that we're trying to regulate but
it's a it's a different animal based on
the pgr can i
can i get can i get you on the record
saying you'll come back and yak with us
in between cutting greens
oh did we lose bill oh we might have
lost phil right before i was about
i was just about to plug his uh green
keeper app too
so uh for everybody still uh still
listening bill
and some other folks doug sold out have
created a website that tracks all these
models we saw some data earlier
growing degree days it's really hard to
check that all yourself if you're making
an excel file
file or whatever bill's green keeper app
has all these models in there the latest
version so
i'm going to put that in the the chat
feed or down in the youtube description
for everybody
um we hit the nail around the head frank
30 minutes
always a fun conversation growth early
in the year uh
gets me hopeful to get out there and
play some golf
so again thanks everybody episode five
of the cornell turf show in the books
uh we'll see you tomorrow thanks very
much everybody see you girl
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu